It's a three-dimensional hole. And one of,
one of my gripes that I have sometimes with how these sorts of things are
portrayed in movies and stuff,
is they tend to think of it as like a circle.
And then you sort of fall in and you go somewhere,
but where it's more of a sphere,
you can approach it from many different directions.
So the other side is sort of a weird thing to think about because it isn't,
you don't mean,
I think the other side so much as you mean the other place it may go to.
So Pete.
No. Are you into the show? Yes, I'm very well. Every week. I'm the same really?
I know I should, I should start differently. Okay. I'll start different. Okay.
So how are your eyes? My eyes, um, just like the year 20,
20, Whoa, gentlemen,
Peter Smeaton dropping the comedy. I would say,
unfortunately that my eyes are also like the year 2020 getting
worse. It seems every month, as you, as people at home can tell, I do,
I do wear glasses are near-sighted.
You can see very well and always have been able to. Right.
I can see a lot of things. I am, I can see everything far away.
I can see through a lot of things like, uh, your, uh, cheesy openings,
but one thing, one thing I can't see through, what do you think black hole?
Exactly. Well, I mean, by definition, very difficult to see through right. Uh,
black they're they're they're large. They're, you know, it's a, it's a,
it's a massive, well, a massive mass that really,
I think only theoretically people believe we could see through, but again,
all due respect to you all due respect to me,
we're not the people who are going to be able to answer that. I know.
So that's why we have experts on the show.
And today we do have an expert from the university of Southern California,
a professor from the physics and astronomy department. You know him,
you love him. He's a friend of the show professor Clifford Johnson.
Welcome back. Welcome back to what if discussed?
Hi, how are you? Okay, good.
Well, we're good. We're, we're kind of debating. Uh, well,
I don't know if we're debating, but we're trying to figure out, you know,
if I was debating, could you see through a black hole?
And obviously this is theoretical. So, you know, this is,
this is the time to be a theoretical physicist. Let's start with Ken.
What would you see if you looked into a black hole?
Uh, that's a great question. So, well,
first approximation in my, you know, physicist way of saying things, uh,
you wouldn't see anything coming from the inside because in some
ways, by definition, at least in classical physics,
the black hole is not letting anything escape from it.
Now,
one of the things people think about a lot in recent times has
been black holes say at the, when you combine them with quantum physics.
Cause when quantum physics is included,
there is some sort of mechanism which goes back to Stephen
Hawking, who you may have heard of. Right? Who said, uh,
and showed that when you combine quantum physics with black holes,
there's a sense in which they radiate stuff out.
And there's a way of thinking about it. That means that in some sense,
the stuff is coming out, uh, energies coming out from the black hole,
it's losing energy.
Now one perspective says it's just some quantum stuff happening near the horizon
and it comes out and it isn't really coming from the inside.
But another perspective says that in some sense,
it is telling you stuff about the inside of a black hole.
So people are very excited about trying to understand the
full quantum story of a black hole,
because it tells you essentially about the fate of the black hole,
the fate of what fell in,
ultimately that stuff all has to come out this
process by which the black hole evaporates. If that is a bet is a real thing.
Now, I shouldn't say that, um, uh, you know,
black holes that we see in astrophysics made from collapsed stars or even
larger, uh, they're they're they're evaporation time. Uh,
and the evaporation effects of the quantum physics are essentially negligible.
They, they,
it would take so long to lose any significant amount of energy that you'd wait
longer than the lifetime of the universe.
So this is very much in the realm of what if in the theoretical physics
world, where you're thinking about the fate of perhaps small black holes,
if they were to be discovered.
You used the term. What if we, it's very,
very rare that we get a get stuck in a plug. It's the show. What if,
so that kind of covers what we would see what might be in a black hole and what
might be emanating from a black hole. Uh,
but if we take this visionary theoretical journey, uh, bright to its conclusion,
what would we see on the other side of a black hole?
Oh, well, that's an interesting question. Uh, debate part of that,
part of the question would then be, I would have to go, well,
what do you mean by the other side? Uh,
if you think of it as, is there another side? Yes,
it's a three-dimensional hole, right. And one of,
one of my gripes that I have sometimes with how this is these sorts of things
that portrayed and movies and stuff, uh,
is they tend to, they tend to,
they tend to think of it as like a circle and then you sort of fall in
and you go somewhere, but where it's, it's more of a, it's more of a sphere.
You can approach it from many different directions and you'd go in.
So the other side is sort of a weird thing to think about because it isn't,
you don't mean, I think the other side so much as you mean the other place,
it may go to can imagine that there's another
spherical object somewhere else, which is like the other end of that hole.
And you would then emerge from outcoming out of that.
And that would be like the exit. Does that make sense? Oh.
Wow. Like a wormhole type thing.
Well that, you know,
those are among the things that people have speculated about and you can
find, uh,
solutions of the equations of relativity,
which is where we study black holes that, that, um,
that give you those scenarios. But the, the plumbing is,
is higher dimensional than we normally think. All right. You think for example,
of, uh, uh, of, uh, uh, like a garden hose, right? As one end,
and that's essentially a circle,
a disc that you go into and then you come out the other end instead you would
have a whole sphere,
which is like a higher dimensional circle. And then you come out the,
a sphere somewhere else. If you were to engineer a wormhole,
as far as we know that, um, that's, uh, that's fraught with, uh,
physics difficulty,
real stable wormholes are not thought to be possible as far as we understand,
but it's fun to think about them. And of course we use them in science fiction,
a law.
And, and Einstein left the door open for that. Didn't he?
Well, he not only left the door open. He, he, he, he helped discover the door,
right? The, the original wormhole, uh, solution,
um, was, was discovered by Einstein and, uh, and Rosen.
And there was a paper where, uh, they actually pointed out that you could,
by examining the geometry of the, of the standard black hole solution,
that's used to study real astrophysical, black holes.
You can actually see that it contains the possibility
of indeed going what seems to be into the black hole
and then coming out another side. And it's like,
you're N you're at like exiting from a different black hole,
or it's the same black hole up to you, how you think about it.
And that was the wormhole solution,
otherwise known as the Einstein Rosen bridge,
a bridge between two different sort of regions,
but as they already observed, uh,
you'd have to do things like move faster than the speed of light to, to, to,
to traverse that wormhole. Um, before it collapsed few,
few nuts to crack that tend to collapse before you can do anything with them.
If, if anybody's seen the, uh,
the opening or seen the show raised by wolves on HBO, max, I believe,
but the opening has them essentially doing exactly what you
just described going through popping out another sphere. Uh, we're checking out.
You can watch, I believe it's just the opening is on YouTube.
It's worth checking out. It's kind of a,
an illustrated vision of that theoretical idea. Um,
theoretical being sort of the key word when we're talking about big wood ifs,
especially something like black holes and looking through them,
but is it possible that these things will be a little less
theoretical,
theoretical and a little more concrete as we develop new technology?
I know that there's the event, horizon telescope and the Virgo cluster,
you know, there's other bigger telescopes go.
Do you anticipate we're going to be able to learn a lot more from these,
these new eyes on these black holes?
Well, well, um, uh, the event horizon telescope is, is, is a wonderful example,
as you say, of what you can do with new technology.
And it's,
in some ways it's new technology combined with old technology in the following
sense while the event horizon telescope is it's actually a network of
existing telescopes and new ones being built will be added.
It's a network of telescopes all around the earth that you connect
together by. Uh,
so you're getting them all to look in the same direction at the same object.
And so that essentially gives you one massive telescope, the size of the earth,
which is what you need in order to see something very far away in great detail.
And, uh,
the technological aspect there is that you need to somehow combine
all that information from all those different telescopes in the right way, uh,
with amazing computer technology,
amazing collaboration by hundreds of scientists, uh,
and they collaborate in order to combine these data using modern algorithms and
super fast computers to do that.
And then essentially turns it into one giant telescope.
So indeed the landmark thing that you probably all saw in the
news, um, what was it last year? I think it was last year, right?
That, that first image all the black hole event horizon,
which I remind you because people often miss this fact,
it's the first time we're seeing in any extended
sense of the word, seeing a black hole,
or at least the event horizon the shadow of the black hole against the stuff
that's glowing around it.
Every other image you've ever seen depicting a black hole has been an
artist impression. It's easy to forget that because, you know,
you see these wonderful artists impressions of matter,
coming off one star on falling into a black hole,
it looks super realistic. An artist did that. Um, except in this case,
this really is real data turned into what it would look like. And so, um,
we're gonna learn a lot more about black holes that way. And, um, I think,
uh, you know,
whether or not the business of whether you can see into it and see out the other
side, or what have you, um, which is,
which is probably going to remain speculative in, in some sense, uh,
we're going to learn a lot about the black holes themselves and, and,
uh, what, how they, how they, uh,
dominate the physics in the core of our galaxy,
how they interact with the stuff there, how they, uh, different,
how different galaxies black holes are different from each other,
as we start imaging other black holes, it's, it's going to be huge. Uh, the,
the amount of stuff we're going to learn from that.
And it is awesome that we're really looking at the shadow of a
black hole with our own eyes, uh, for the first time in our history,
you know, civilizations, history.
Spectacular, super cool professor.
Thanks very much for taking us through this speculative vision quest. Uh,
where can people go to find your work?
Well? Um,
it's probably easiest to find me on either Instagram or Twitter or
Facebook by just, well, just Google my name and physics,
Clifford Johnson physics. That's the easiest way,
rather than trying to figure out what.
I w I would also, sorry, go on. I was just going to say, that's what I did.
And it brought me down the whole Clifford Johnson rabbit hole too.
So I would it, to your point, it's the best place to start.
Clifford Johnson physics may be USC as well.
Yeah. And you'll find, uh, you'll find, uh, uh, like I said, uh, lots of,
lots of, uh, thoughts, discussions on my blog, um,
images I share of, uh, physics ideas or other things, um,
uh, other activities I get up to,
and you'll find your way maybe also to my non-fiction graphic book about,
um, the nature of the universe. I wish I wrote and drew a couple of years ago,
published by MIT press.
There's a lot of ideas in there about space and time and quantum physics,
a little bit about black holes and how you can use them as time machines,
for example, and things like that.
Thank you, professor Johnson, uh, in quantum physics,
there's something called the observer effect,
which is very interesting in that literally what you see and what I see
of the same thing might be different.
So when you apply it to especially things as theoretical as black holes,
when we're asking, well, what would you see if you saw through a black hole?
Well, of course, you know, beauty is in the eye of the beholder, as they say,
who knows what you're going to see,
but at least when you talk to somebody like professor Johnson,
you at least get a better guidance system on what you'd be looking for.
Because here I'm asking that question in a two dimensional sense,
and I hadn't even thought that, of course that's idiotic. Yeah.
They say there's no dumb questions, but maybe that was, yeah,
no, I always thought too, that a black hole is just a, you know,
it's a hole and you fall into it not realizing it's physical or it's
three-dimensional of course it's not a black hole. It's a black aura. Yes,
exactly. Really.
He sort of helped us understand that and helps us understand a few others.
Right? Well, we'll be seeing more black holes not coming up anytime soon. Uh,
as our.
Technology gets a stronger,
as we send a Hubble or web telescopes into space and get a better look and
usher in basically a new era of space exploration. Uh,
and we'll also explore a little bit more with the professor Johnson on the
extended audio podcasts. Now,
if you're watching us and you want to hear more,
we'll just click on the link below and you can join the extended audio podcasts.
If you are already listening to the audio podcasts, don't worry.
There's nothing to click on. Just keep listening.
We'll be with you in just a second now. Uh,
if you are watching on video and you're leaving us, we'll thanks for joining us.
We'll see you next week on another. What if discussed.